[Applause]
what's up everybody uh welcome to
flagrant two
okay my name is andrew schultz i'm here
with akash
singh alex media mark gagnon taylor's in
the building the
born again off again uh fifth wheel
of this podcast we're glad to have you
back make sure you keep those notes on
point though
okay we need those notes taylor today's
a big episode
we got some big information we gotta
drop big
netflix got a schultz special
[Laughter]
they landed the big fish okay
the bottle knows dolphin is that the one
with the biggest nose
yeah moby dick yeah we got dove mammon
in the building too
um you can't hear him because he doesn't
have a mic but we love him
and um we're going to tell you a story
about
all the things that happened to get us
where we are today i'm absolutely
[ __ ] exhausted i know alex media is
exhausted i know mark gagnon's exhaust i
know dove ma'am is exhausted
uh we've been working our ass off on
this project and uh we're very excited
to show it uh
to all of you on the 17th man it's going
to be on netflix and
i want to break records for the the
watch list so make sure you add it to
your watch list and then
tell them to let you know when it when
it releases because uh
yeah i think that there's a little trick
there that we're going to use but yeah
i'm so excited for you guys to see this
man we've been working so hard on this
for the last three months some of you
guys knew we were up to something
charlemagne damn near said i was having
a child
my girl was getting all these dms right
because somehow some of you psychos
found my girl's instagram she's getting
dms she hit me and she's like
are we pregnant
because i'm getting all these
congratulations dm so i guess charlotte
may set on idiots
that i was pregnant that you're pregnant
yeah and then
he goes no i was just using it as a
metaphor and i listened back and all he
says was
charles is pregnant that's not a
metaphor that's just saying i'm [ __ ]
pregnant
so bank account about to be pregnant yes
the banking kid is special the bank
i right the bank account all right right
now [ __ ] might change a little bit but
uh
but yeah man i'm just really excited and
i just i'm very proud of this thing i
can't wait for y'all to see it man and
i'm just so grateful for all y'all for
watching
the monologues we've been doing
basically what we did is our weekly
monologues we did
as an uh four-part hour-long special
that's a year and
review essentially is tapping into four
of the biggest most divisive events of
this year
and obviously coronavirus we got
conspiracy theories black lives matter
and of course a nation divided so uh i'm
just so excited to see this man and
for you guys to see it and uh i
understand i was saying this earlier
but i understand that like i'm gonna get
the the credit for this obviously
because i'm the leader of the band if
you will and the lead singer
but this was a monumental effort by
so many other people you know first of
all i've got to congratulate mark mark
is a co-creator of this show man
he wrote oh yeah and and this is a big
move he did an absolutely great job not
only during this show but also the 17
weeks that you put in
before you [ __ ] kill that you grind
and i'm so proud of you and you you
you murdered it man i'm so grateful to
have you part of it alex media made his
directorial debut
okay that's right let's go that's right
and you
absolutely murdered it man i was so
proud of you you stepped up to the
occasion
you were too confident you were too
confident i thought you were gonna be
insecure
i thought you were gonna be like nervous
telling people what to do but alex was
back there man he was just snapping at
[ __ ] telling him where to be
what angles he wanted i was so impressed
that [ __ ] was so funny why did you guys
think that because inside i was
really i was nervous you know what
honestly i would i would say after the
first shoot date i even said to you i
was like man you were so confident back
there you really rose to the occasion
yeah i was not i was nervous uh i was so
great that's what i said i've been on
al didn't know all the lingo but he knew
exactly what he wanted yeah so he was
just telling all the [ __ ] to do [ __ ]
just being like yeah make it more like
this like this way yeah and they were
like all right
yeah that's how we communicate don't
understand that you got to speak to mark
like alexa
you know you can't like if you got mark
don't understand it unless you ask a
very specific
what is the weather today but if you go
what's it like outside he'll be like oh
i missed that civil unrest actually now
you mentioned it but um also i gotta i
gotta congratulate dove
dove is my first friend that i ever made
in college
uh he's one of my best friends in the
world and he's been working in
entertainment you know toiling in
obscurity for years and uh i thought
that we should save him
by bringing him on to this product now
in all seriousness he's absolutely
brilliant guy and
i knew when we were younger we were
going to do something together you know
when we were in college we were thinking
about doing a radio show together and
then we realized we had to be
up at 3am to do that [ __ ] we're like nah
we'd rather be fingering
chicks but uh
but for real we always knew we were
gonna do something and he went on to
great things in hollywood and the second
i had this opportunity i was like we
need him here and he was an integral
part in
uh not only getting this done but giving
us so much jewish anxiety that it's
unbelievable dude
dude i don't know how you are not
shredded from stress
like he lives in this dude it's
unbelievable
he's comfy in the fire this guy will
find problems you didn't even know
existed
it's like a [ __ ] cloud around
pull himself it's a gravitational pull
it was unbelievable
so uh so yeah so everything was going
great until akash shut the whole thing
down with corona it was
i sure did dude literally things the
first shoot we were all so
proud of it we're like oh this is going
great we're all ahead of schedule we get
the writing down everything is great
then akash gives you a text he's like yo
man i got corona
yeah man and and i'm the type of guy and
i mean this sincerely and this is
something that
before this really tested me because i'm
the type of guy that's like
everything happens for a reason but i
don't mean that in like a corny sense
like you know when a child gets cancer
or whatever like that obviously that
doesn't happen for a [ __ ] reason but
like
my mentality on life is that if you
i consider myself a problem solver so
it's like if you look at everything in
front of you and figure out how you can
pro
you know problem solve and use it to
your advantage you'll start to believe
that things are happening for you that
there's some greater power out there
looking out for you
when in reality you're creating your
luck by taking whatever circumstances
you've been given and making the best
out of them right
it was hard for me to get there when you
get that [ __ ] bro when you gave us
corona bro
i needed a good three days dude i was
like what is the lesson here what
how do i learn from this right yeah what
and
man i was so angry and it was so unfair
because
you didn't want to give us corona bro
those were
physically corona didn't affect me
emotionally emotionally
the darkest week and a half of my life i
gave it to the people i work with the
most who are working on the biggest
project of their lives
i don't and you also don't know who got
what until they test
i saw my in-laws the day before one of
them is in his 60s
i'm freaking the [ __ ] out like did i
[ __ ] is this guy going to get corona
that's a power move right there i'm the
only daddy now
no bro and then [ __ ] when we did
history hyenas i gave i might have given
it to them and
distefano was like i know what you're
going to do you're going to let shells
become emperor
and then you're going to take them out
and i'm like what the [ __ ] just happened
no
he said that i christie probably left
some [ __ ] corona potion on the seat
or something
i thought about every single thing that
happened on sunday and monday before i
got my test
that's all you're doing for five days
when you're waiting for everybody to get
the results so i come in monday feeling
[ __ ] fantastic
do a podcast with the hyenas it's great
whatever
go home that night feel fine tuesday the
next day
afternoon i start feeling like a little
body ache and [ __ ] yeah but i just
worked out really hard the day before
he felt fine monday giannis yes
okay important to know jan is going
around spreading his [ __ ] lie
akash felt sick and still came into the
[ __ ] studio
i would never in my [ __ ] life but
also
not only let's say you didn't care about
giannis yeah or
chris you're getting it yeah you're not
going to walk in the studio where we're
creating the netflix special right and
then infect everybody and shut that down
never uh it actually i think helped us
in the law in the in the grand scheme of
things in the moment we would have never
been able to tell
but having that extra time allowed us to
like analyze certain scripts
make more images and like really look at
the flow of the content
in a way that we would have been able to
because of shooting schedules so
when i say everything happens for a
reason this might have been the reason
that it actually happened i will say
this
thank [ __ ] god you did not come to
the engagement dinner
yeah because you would have killed my
parents yeah
you couldn't come remember he couldn't
come to the engagement dinner because it
was on diwali
yeah he was on diwali and um
bruh i mean imagine though
diwali saved it bro yo thank god thank
god
who do we praise for that one for dwight
all of them
you give there's just a holiday for all
the gods no
cheap indian [ __ ] dishing out
holidays
come on no i'm just saying thank god in
general at work
but this holidays for rum oh dang wrong
bro yeah
well look man i it's uh it's a wild time
i'm very excited for you guys to see
this man i'm very grateful
sorry [ __ ] it's all my fault but we
back yo
[ __ ] be back bro you know we're not
leaving you unless it was something that
um
was out of our control and this was out
of our control but [ __ ] a man
it's good to be back we worked our asses
on this man we [ __ ] bled on this i'm
telling you left it all on the table
i saw them grinding it was unreal like
yeah
just [ __ ] non-stop even robbie i'm
sorry i got to make sure
did i did i compliment i don't know
what's going on i don't know if yeah
that's what i was about to say like but
i complimented you
on this we recorded earlier but there
was a problem with one of the cameras
um and i also want to compliment uh just
thank
uh robbie slovik a hilarious comic that
wrote on the
uh show with us and also fal guy who's
never written comedy in his life
uh for just jumped on board and he
absolutely killed it man he was
so helpful and there's a million other
people we need to thank you
actually i really want to thank this one
guy who is an editor on this john
raffanelli
yo legend exactly this guy's a [ __ ]
legend thank you so much john we're
going to steal you from
jax media the production companies
there's going to be another time where i
actually thank everybody so i want
people thinking that i'm not being
thankful for you right now we're going
to really go for the official one but i
just needed to shout those specific
people out
and then two other people out i got a
shout out justin bieber
uh and because justin bieber shared my
stuff he shares my stuff with a lot of
people man he's a [ __ ] great guy for
that
and love the bibs yo love the beeps
shout out to the beeps but also uh
scooter braun because justin shared this
with scooter
and scooter and i started talking and
figuring out what we wanted to
potentially do with this
and um and that dude is legit man i will
give credit where credit is due that
[ __ ]
is legit at what he does there's a lot
of useless managers and agents out there
yeah okay most of them but that guy
is skilled and talented and i he is
where he is he moves the world
facts facts facts so yeah we're very
excited about this man i cannot even
begin we're going to tell you more about
in the time it comes but like
i cannot even begin to tell you how many
little things are in this special
little jokes that only the [ __ ] will
get little things are in pictures that
only the [ __ ] will get
you know i mean i mean there's so many
tiny little things in here
i there's not a single person on the
planet that will be able to get every
single joke that's in this special
there's a lot
if you were to guess how many you think
did how many jokes you think
in the whole thing yeah i was trying to
calculate that really yeah
if you count the jokes that are in the
pictures yeah yeah
thousands yeah i mean it's dude
there's no way you could get every
single one of it i literally think it's
going to be like uh
you know like a jay-z album where you
listen to it again and you're like oh he
said that
yeah you know or like one of those
movies like a a nolan movie where you
like watch it for the second time you're
like oh that happened
like i literally think you're gonna you
could watch each episode four times and
you probably won't get every single
joke every single switch in the picture
like so many of us are in the pictures
obviously you're gonna notice you know
us but you'll notice i mean akash might
even be
you know in some stuff you never know
you know
you never know bro you never know it's
also it's also really cool because like
projects like these a lot of times like
people will just bring on a bunch of
people to like do all the stuff
you know like you'll bring in like
directors bring in editors whatever yeah
like
for this project it was us in this room
that did
what the whole thing 95 percent i'm be
honest it really was
and like i wouldn't have it any other
way because at the end of the day for
for this project i want to be able
i i know that we put out the exact thing
we want to put out
you know what i mean like it's different
when you put out a project and you're
like well this is what they let me
this is what we want to do there's
nothing in this project that we didn't
want to do
um we hired a production company uh jax
media
and uh shouts out to them man they
handled the you know the legal the
paying for stuff but they also had some
great staff over there as well
and um and all the picture editors
killed it the picture editors killed it
and shout to miles mccreery man
i cannot even begin to tell you man i
put my faith
in people that are talented there's one
thing i'll compliment myself on
uh and there's a lot more than one
i can recognize talent bro and uh
i'll be honest i i really believe that
myself and i mean that and the first
thing i look for is competence
in human beings and i saw it with alex
when we first started working together
and i was like yeah he don't know how to
[ __ ] edit
but he'll learn you know what i mean
he'll figure it out the first thing you
sent me was [ __ ] do you remember it yeah
it was horrible but i was like but he
will learn
how to do it what was it it was horrible
dude it was so bad
it was so bad you know what but it was
like you were doing
the joke of the day or something like
that he like kind of animated the joke
of the day he like
added pictures in it it was almost like
this low-key oh [ __ ] i created this [ __ ]
i'll be honest with you this is this
show i did a long time ago with my
brother
all right this american house called
this american hype there's still some
episodes that are up there
when i first reached out to you uh via
dm i was asking you to bring that [ __ ]
back
because i actually liked that episode it
was a great show it took it took a lot
of time and
shout outs to my brother greg man and um
but i just yes bring this back i mean
also we got to give a shout out to bill
maher
bill maher is the reason why we started
doing these monologues
he did a monologue about why he wasn't
racist to call it the china virus
and so many people were sending me this
thing around and i had this thought for
a while but i was like
oh people really need an explanation for
their
feeling that is not politically correct
they feel it they just don't know how to
articulate in a way that won't be costly
at their job in their social circle et
cetera
and i remember i hit up mark and i was
like yeah we you see this thing
we can do this ten times better and
justin bill maher
we bro there's so many shots bro it's
just so crazy bro
and um it's so crazy i can't give away
too much but it's so crazy
seeing the people in real life that we
give shots to because i've interacted
with them kind of some people
mm-hmm and uh can you name any yeah the
guy
dale from the bachelorette
which one is dale he's the most recent
season he's back like you don't watch
i'm glad you gave him a shot [ __ ] that
guy cornball ass yeah
hey there [ __ ] yo we gotta do
bachelorette recaps out this [ __ ]
we got it all planned so um
but yeah man it's just it's just so much
fun yeah that's another cool thing about
it equal opportunity
yeah i mean like everybody gonna get
these jokes jokes everywhere and when we
say everybody
we mean everybody okay ah i'm just
excited for y'all to see it man i'm so
proud of it
we're just watching it down how do you
guys feel man how was your experience
with it
i haven't taken it all in yet no yeah yo
al really had no clue what the schedules
were
it's amazing we were making fun of him
last night about this [ __ ] this guy was
so
removed from like what was going on
because yeah i get stressed and [ __ ]
like not me
mark could be getting stressed you lose
get you stressed
you might get me stressed over and over
again
what happened what happens if we don't
get it by two i go well then we'll get
they'll get it when we get it because we
have dates that you have to hit yeah
right or that they give you dates and
then we you know
move those dates to be honest from the
outside i've always felt the opposite i
always felt like mark is just living
oh nah you shouldn't say this
[ __ ] was stressed oh my god
you know you've
so uh there's rules to life okay nah
that's
[ __ ] up this guy he asked me the same
[ __ ] question four times in a row so
what happens if we do it and it's like
bro
they're gonna get it when they [ __ ]
get it's the ten commandments okay what
about them when you're right now
meet deadlines what commandment is that
yeah when you're raised with strict
deadlines and rules
okay that are written out you gotta
believe you gotta obey him you know
i don't know what this excuse that he's
making is right now but
anyway al didn't even know how to use
the editing system that we edited on
eight days before the [ __ ] thing
started
okay we at al edits in final cut pro
yeah like a 14 year old
premiere is the professional program
still be fire i know it's just very much
stuff
it says still be fire but now we got to
edit right i even told him this months
before we started this i was like you
have to start learning premiere i will
pay for you to take classes and premiere
and then he came to me once he was like
nah you could just do it on final cut
and then there's a
codec or he said some word i don't know
what the [ __ ] meant and then he goes
then we'll just transfer it over to
premiere and i go
all right even though i knew it wasn't
all right yeah not it's really a system
that you could do i know but it's not
going to allow the other guys to work
with it too
so then i go al did you learn how to do
it you goes now i got it every once in a
while i pop into edit and this guy on
one screen
has youtube tutorials he thinks i don't
notice his youtube tutorials
how do you separate audio video i was
like we're not going to finish this
special
right thank god i didn't tell mark or
[ __ ] that's why he had to pay by
himself because he's got to learn
premieres
real talk if dove didn't knew about this
forget it bro
forget it bro he'd been spinning like a
dreidel dude
he just loses [ __ ] mud tasmanian
devil that's what job is
jewish what's that mary's easier than
final cut though
nah final cut is mad easy premiere is
[ __ ] tricky that was nice yes it is
no
it's like i'm talking like i know either
[Applause]
one
you